good evening everyone everyone online
and everyone here in the studio I'm
Adrian more I'm vice president of policy
at the reason foundation and i'm joined
by carl demaio who's made a career out
of government reform most recently
serving on the San Diego City Council
and running for mayor in San Diego we're
going to talk some tonight about issues
issues in California and specifically
about pension issues government pension
issues in California we've started
something here at reason we call the
California reform initiative we have
this crazy idea that maybe even
California can be turn around and even
California can be saved from in a sense
the ravages of over large government I
and I so I guess my first question Carl
is the youth is how crazy is that do you
think California can be saved absolutely
we're quickly running out of money in
the state of California we've been
running out of jobs by driving
investment and businesses out of our
state we've run out of services and
infrastructure and we're quickly running
out of time and so it can be turned
around California can be saved but it
requires immediate action and a
commitment by our political years to
actually make serious structural reform
not transactional reform but
transformational reform rethinking how
we operate as a state rethinking how we
create conditions where people want to
move to California want to raise a
family they want to start that first
business they want to invest they want
to hire that first employee they want to
hire that 15th employee and so those
issues can be addressed if we have a
real and genuine commitment by political
leaders to do the right thing and that's
what the projects about the projects
about generating bold ideas
on how to solve California's looming
challenges it's about raising public
awareness so that Californians know that
they don't have to accept a failed state
that we don't have to accept the fate of
higher taxes more regulation and less
services a diminished quality of life
and that they can be part of the
solution that the people can take back
control of their government whether it's
their local government at City Hall or
whether it's our state government in
Sacramento and position our city our
state for success again so it's going to
involve I think not only the idea
generation in in a number of areas but
it's going to involve a public education
a public mobilization process to put
pressure on political leaders to take
action on reform well there's a lot of
issues where I think any individual
online or in the audience could say oh I
think California needs to fix this or
you know there's a lot of potential
worst problems in Calvary I think you
and I have agreed that that the
government pension problems and the
unsustainability of the benefits that
have been promised and the inadequacy of
the investments that are being made to
pay for those benefits is a tangible
immediate problem that not only has to
be addressed but probably can be
addressed if enough people sort of
realize the scope of the problem and the
potential solution so I want to get into
that a little bit and I guess the
starting point is most people have no
idea really they may have heard
government pensions are a problem but
they don't know how big it is how big it
is nationwide and how big it is in
California so could you explain that a
little bit sure the government pension
crisis across the country is a three
trillion dollar crisis using today's
numbers using what we know today three
trillion dollars and to put that in
perspective you would have to pass six
tax bills that we just passed in January
the big tax increase in Washington six
of those bills to pay for the three
trillion dollars over the next ten
years in the state of California you're
talking about roughly 500 billion
dollars in debt 500 billion dollars in
liabilities those are big numbers a
billion here a trillion there but let's
really point out the impact to people's
lives day to day what it means is higher
taxes higher water bills because most of
our water is delivered by government
systems it means less services it means
a commute in the morning that is clogged
with potholes it means less after-school
programs for our children go down the
list of things that people look to
government to be at least involved in if
not providing and you will find that
these programs have been cut back year
after year after year and yet
government's collecting more and more
money year after year after year so
we're spending more and we're getting
less and that's really the I think the
best way to show the impact of pension
costs that are skyrocketing will be the
loss of services that we've seen in the
past decade and the higher cost of
living higher costs of operating in
every located location in the state of
California city county and of course the
state government if you don't reform
government pensions no tax increase is
going to be big enough no service cut
will be deep enough to avoid bankruptcy
you can continue to raise taxes you can
continue to gut services and we will
still be bankrupt and that's why this is
the most important issue to start with
and I also believe that by solving the
pension crisis we will build capacity we
will build public trust and
participation we will build a governing
majority that will allow us to tackle
other issues down the line you know you
get pensions reformed then let's turn
and look at other areas of waste in
government can we open up government
services to outsourcing and competition
can we look at public-private
partnerships can we look at
decentralising services to a
local level can we embrace technology to
deliver services into interactive
citizens in a dramatically different way
those are easy challenges if you can
overcome the resistance to pension
reform the government employee unions
the fact that politicians and the judges
benefit from these pensions themselves
if you could overcome that many of these
other issues are much more are more
easily accomplished because you have
success at your back and you have really
overcome perhaps the biggest obstacle to
reform in the state well I first really
realized myself how severe the
government pension problem was when on
in order to write a column for my local
newspaper I had to calculate the fire
department pension costs into the future
and what I realized that is that by the
time my first kid graduates from college
the fire department in my community will
be paying more money per year to retired
workers than they will be two people who
are actually working then and and so you
know nothing could be more unsustainable
than a system where your overtime you're
paying more and more people who are not
working and fewer and fewer people who
are working that system is just going to
collapse so I want to break down a
little bit how we got into that pickle
and and what I what I hear a lot I think
represents sort of the common views is
that is this a question of the
government has just set benefits too
high or is it that they that the
benefits are reasonable but they're
simply not putting enough into the
investment funds that are supposed to
pay for those benefits on investment
returns down the line or is it some
combination of the two well if you
listen to the people who are trying to
defend the status quo the government
employee unions they'll say there is no
crisis that if you just pump a little
bit more money in and we have a couple
more investment gains if the stock
market does a bit better that all will
be well it's sort of like that gambling
addict who thinks that if they just
could get one more buy-in on the poker
table that they will get that perfect
hand and they'll be able to get on that
winning streak it's simply not
sustainable it's not been the investment
losses it's not been intentional
underfunding although that has occurred
in these pension systems it's been the
spike in benefits it's promising too
much we have low retirement ages age 54
public safety in most jurisdictions 55
for everyone else that's the retirement
age in government 55 you should be done
you should be in tahoe you should be in
Maui age 55 now I know a lot of
hard-working taxpayers out there who
look at age 65 67 70 and are wondering
whether they can actually afford
retirement at those ages because of the
cost of government because of the
taxation because of the burdens in the
private sector and so there's is there
is an inequity in terms of the benefit
that's offered we see many government
employees retiring earning more in
pension payouts in their first year then
their highest salary working now you
know it's a government idea when you're
paid more not to work then you were
actually paid to work and a lot of these
pension systems have benefits that allow
government employees to earn more in
their first year of pension payouts than
in the highest year of salary we had a
study done in San Diego where I asked
the Mercer actuarial company what does
the average city employee get if they
have 30 year service the answer was the
average city employee 30 year service
not police and fire we're talking about
a blue collar white collar employee will
receive a hundred and twenty-nine
percent of their highest salary for life
129 percent and we have a number of
other abuses in the system for example
in San Diego individuals are allowed to
retire in place and during the last five
years of their employment with the city
they enter a program called drop
deferred retirement option plan where
they receive not only a full salary but
they receive a full pension
simultaneously and these drop pensions
or we call double dippers they are able
to then retire and receive their base
pension
plus a 25-year annuity funded off of the
drop proceeds so you keep peeling back
the onion and you find abuses pensions
are calculated not on the last salary
regular salary but they are calculated
based on all compensation bonus pay add
on pay specialty pay vacation pay sick
pay to spike that pension calculation in
the city of San Diego we had a an
example of innovation where our parking
meters used to have attendance going
around on foot giving tickets and
checking the meters well in past decade
the city decided to get scooters and
these scooters were given to the
employees and the idea was that we would
make this investment make our employees
more efficient they can get around
quicker put those tickets on the cars
quicker and it would be an easier work
environment for them because they're not
walking they actually are just driving a
scooter the union said thank you very
much we appreciate this device but you
know it takes a very talented person to
drive a scooter and as a result we
believe our employees should receive
scooter pay scooter pays about 5% bonus
pay annually now for some of the union's
these people receive scooter paid even
when they're not driving the scooter if
you're on vacation you get scooter pay
on vacation and of course when you
retire you get your scooter pay added to
your final compensation so you know you
can't make this stuff up in the private
sector it just doesn't happen so when
people say well what's the little root
of the pension crisis is that the
investment losses is it that we didn't
pay enough into the system you know
that's happened but the real driver has
been an unsustainable system of benefits
that promises too much that promises a
level of benefit that no taxpayer
receives themselves that are being asked
to foot the bill you don't see this
happening in the private sector of the
nonprofit sector you see it happening in
government and I think really
more than just the financial cost
savings of pension reform and we're
talking billions of dollars of savings
savings that can be put back into
programs and reducing the cost of
government the real issue here is
fairness and equity why should we have a
governing class receive a better benefit
than the people they are supposed to
serve then the hard-working taxpayers
are footing the bill and might I add
that the politicians typically receive
the sweetest the best benefits in the
city San Diego when we did an
examination of benefit payouts we found
that our youngest pensioner started
earning his pension at age 31 I was
shocked how can someone at age 31
receive a pension well it was a city
council member who was convicted of a
felony and ejected from office and of
course automatically started receiving a
pension on day one after the conviction
and that's because the City Council
members the politicians set their
retirement age at 0 they start receiving
their pension immediately p immediately
upon leaving office we see other
politicians that have left the city
council after eight years of service
they are termed out then they go get
elected to the state assembly or the
state Senate they receive a pension and
a taxpayer salary simultaneously and so
the politicians themselves have reserved
some of the best benefits for their
class and so there's this secret society
no one wants to reform because if you
reform one side ultimately the gig is up
for everyone the dominoes fall well
there's nothing more to be said than
about why reform is so hard to happen to
it when our prime beneficiaries are the
very ones who have to execute the reform
you you've got a huge problem well
before we I want to talk a little bit
about actually how we do reform and what
you guys did in in San Diego but before
just to go back you you you mentioned
that you didn't think there was that
much deliberate failure to save in to
invest adequately in order to pay for
these benefits I'm not so sanguine about
it I think I adding a lot of city
councils
accepted reports from staff projecting
fantastic market returns for their
pension plans that none of them would
accept from their broker with their own
personal investments and and then
they've doubled down on this I mean most
people have not heard of this insidious
thing called a pension obligation bond
this is where the government says oh my
gosh we don't have enough money this
year we're supposed to pay let's say the
city of X is supposed to pay 150 million
this year into the pension fund in order
to have enough years down the road to
pay for benefits we don't have 150
million because we just gave big raises
and we hired a bunch of people and we
started a new program in and etc etc so
I know we'll sell some bonds so we'll
borrow the money to pay for a future
debt so we'll double down on the debt
with with double interest compounded and
this has become a common practice now in
California absolutely and and but again
you see that happening it's a major
problem but the root cause of all of
that continues to be promises that
cannot be sustained benefits that we
would never see in the private sector
because business and it owners the
private sector executives nonprofit
managers know that if they would have
give these benefits away they'd go
bankrupt and they'd probably go to jail
in the / in the government sector you
have seen two things happen to try to
mask the debt one is they use rosy
scenarios on investment returns and
Rosie scenarios on liabilities so they
are assuming eight percent seven and a
half percent guaranteed annual return on
investment every year for 30 years in
each and every year now if you can make
eight percent a year or seven half
percent a year guaranteed every year for
30 years I'm giving you my money right
now and so there are Rosie's scenarios
in the city of San Diego we also have a
policy called surplus earnings now in a
defined benefit plan I don't know how
you could have something called the
surplus earnings because in good years
you should keep your surplus earnings
your investment gains for years where
you're naturally going to have a market
downturn so you a ver Ajay to a stable
rate of return
the city of San Diego we give our
retirees a 13th check to pay out those
surplus earnings so it's a very abusive
system and then of course as you
mentioned they [ __ ] all the upside and
the taxpayers get all the pension
obligation bonds the pension obligation
bonds again is paying one credit card
with another and these came into use in
the 1980s where politicians would say
well not only are we cash poor but I
think we can beat the market you know
we're only going to pay five percent six
percent four percent on the pension
obligation bond because it's a municipal
bond and we believe that we can get
better than eight percent maybe we get
nine percent return this year maybe get
ten percent and so we can actually make
some money and put that money into
paying down our liability and so the
government finance Officers Association
which you know tends to look at things
from a government point of view even
they had to admit this is like a poker
player going to a loan shark to double
down on his last hand no I think it's
actually worse than that it's like me
going to my credit union where I can get
a low-interest personal loan in order to
invest in the stock market because I
believe that I can beat my loan interest
rate with my stock market gains I mean
if that worked who needs capitalism we
could all just be rich just it's just
it's a sweet little turn around and and
it doesn't work you brought up jail and
I thought that this a number of times
when I look this if any private sector
CEO or board of directors made pay
decisions for their employees based on
their what they expected to come in the
coming year and predicted revenues and
expenses for the coming year and failed
so abjectly Lee both in terms of the
return on the benefits and the return on
the investments so that they lost money
they would be turfed right out by the
stockholders of that company and yet
we've got city government after county
government after state government here
that makes that mistake over and over
again nobody even knows well we only
have a little while left so I do want to
talk about reforms because well we've
we've said
enough about how big the problem is i
think in san diego right now San Diego
is probably the brightest and most
shining example of what can be done in
pension reform there's a long ways to go
obviously to get through executing all
of those reforms but can you talk just a
little bit about what did you guys
change in San Diego and maybe a little
bit about what was other than the
obvious the union's the biggest barrier
you were up against first we closed our
pension system and decided that we would
give our city employees the same
benefits that taxpayers receive Social
Security and a 401k and we benchmarked
it to the penny against what the
Department of Labor has measured in san
diego county is the average contribution
that employer provides for a 401k so to
the penny its dollar for dollar equality
and that also requires that we pay our
bill when it's due we that we pay a
defined contribution each and every year
and that there's no hidden liability
that bites taxpayers down the line
second we are the only system that
figured out how to reform existing
government employee pensions and I
really if you walk away with only one
bit of information out of this webinar
know that pensions for existing
employees can be reformed now the
politicians and the government unions
will want you to believe that that's all
set in stone that there's no way to
reform it but we have shown in San Diego
that there are many ways to reform it
first and foremost we decided hey we may
not be able to change the formulas and
the benefits directly but we can charge
you 100 percent of your fair
contribution for the benefit amazing
thing happens when you charge someone
the cost of a Cadillac they start asking
about the you go they want a more
affordable model and so that leads to
the second reform which is you may not
be able to force someone out of a vested
contract but you can enter into an
amendment to that contract on a
voluntary basis and so we allow under
our ballot measure people to opt out of
defined benefit plans into 401 k plans
on a go-forward basis why would they
want to do that because they want to be
paying the high contribution rate each
and every year
we mandate and third pensions are based
on a formula you get your years of
service times a multiplier it's three
percent in the city for police and fire
at age 50 two-point-five percent per
year for everyone else at age 55 can't
change that multiplier but it's
multiplied by your last salary or
highest salary what we decided to do was
change what that last salary would be we
said that would only be based on the
base salary no no bonus pays and
specialty pay so the scooter pay
sayonara it's gone and second of all we
froze the assumed increase in pay
government employees under the city of
San Diego model were assumed to receive
a guaranteed five percent increase in
their compensation each and every year
automatic increase in compensation what
I said was what would happen if we
flatlined at zero if you flatline at
zero your liability drops particularly
over a 30-year period over a 15-year
period over a five-year period and your
annual payment therefore drops as well
and the payout for that employee would
be also lower more conservative more
reasonable when they retire so we froze
pensionable pay calculations for five
years combined this ballot measure saves
one to two billion dollars under the
most conservative cost-saving estimates
and it's really a philosophical change
in employee compensation under the rule
that you should receive no more no less
than the labor market that you operate
in then the hard-working taxpayers
themselves receive and when people said
that the politics would never allow for
this that we were you know going to have
the unions come in we understood that
the unions were going to oppose but we
felt that if we could get this to a
public vote and have the people decide
that they would agree the city of San
Diego voting demographics are the same
as the state of California plus or minus
one percent on every demographic the
same number of Democrats Republicans
independents Republicans are a third
party in the city of San Diego and so we
put this measure on the ballot and it
carried every political party
it carried every council district every
socio-economic group including Latinos
and african-americans and Asians it is
such a no-brainer that we need pension
reform that if we could get this on the
ballot in the state of California that
it would pass overwhelmingly and reform
would be achieved so the question is how
do we overcome the barriers how do we
overcome the labor unions and that
really is up to the efforts in the next
year 18 months of educating the public
shining a light on the problem exposing
the real cost and liability but also
translating it really into a fairness
argument why should you pay more in
taxes so that we have a librarian in San
Diego walk out with a 234 thousand
dollar a year annual pension why should
you have cuts in your after-school
programs or why should your pothole not
be filled or why should you not be able
to get a first responder to your home
and the National Response time or better
so that we can have a forty five percent
increase in the number of six-figure
pensions which we've seen happen in the
state of California over the past two
years so when you put it in those terms
you can easily build a majority case in
the state of California in the people
who matter who can actually make a
difference and I don't believe that's
the politicians it's the voting is all
organized it's the big general public
that we have to be able to reach and
educate and it's not just San Diego San
Jose also passed pretty substantive bold
as San Diego's but pretty substantial
reforms a few other communities like
Bakersfield have passed a more modest
but very meaningful reforms getting
employees to retire and a more
reasonable time to contribute more to
their pension benefits and to change the
formulas for new employees so they don't
get these over-the-top benefits raining
it all in so there's a bit of a move
afoot and I think as Carl said if we can
get this going statewide we can have a
huge impact on California's fiscal
situation we have just a few moments
left a few minutes
sorry and I want to turn to our studio
audience and see if we have any
questions on this or related issues from
them talking about reform I like your
ideas what about on the people that are
already retired short of bankruptcy is
that be much a lacquered it's very
difficult to reform benefits and so
we've always said there are three
classes or three opportunities for
reform there's new employees which
should be a no-brainer we ought to be
doing that yesterday there's existing
employees you can implement reforms as
we've done in San Diego to slowly reduce
the debt and slowly reduce your annual
cost of pensions but for people already
retired legally there are we haven't
found any options right now and even in
bankruptcy in the state of California
the state constitution presumably
provides an ironclad guarantee for
vested benefits particularly for people
who are already retired so we have
focused on the first two area employees
and existing employees and I believe
that you are able to fix the financial
crisis and pensions with just those two
classes is it fair no it's not because
there are a lot of six-figure pensioners
that are out there there's that X
politician earning a pension starting at
age 31 but as much as we'd like to
change that the law does not allow us to
do that and so we want to make sure that
we are implementing reforms that stand
up in court get those locked in
immediately and then see if we can
address some of the structural problems
with the existing retirees I think
there's also a fairness argument for the
vast majority of employees many of them
earn who particularly who retired prior
to 2000 in the state of California
before benefits were spiked by many
jurisdictions they earned modest
pensions and in fact their retirement
security is threatened by all these new
benefits that have been voted in and so
there's a sense of equity that people
have already retired
let's try it let's try to facilitate and
protect and reform the system and avoid
bankruptcy for those individuals Carl
when you're talking about making a
change at the state level getting
something on the state ballot how does
that impact the other municipalities can
the state mandate how a city calculate
the answer is yes the state constitution
can put in place reforms on both state
and local governments the concern I've
always had is that the state legislature
has been going the opposite direction
they're always passing bills that make
it more costly and more generous for
these pensions and so by moving it
through the initiative process and
putting this in the hands of the people
there's an opportunity to reset the
clock statewide the reason why statewide
reform is also necessary is that you
don't want to have competition problems
where San Diego reforms its pension
system and then a neighboring city like
chula vista or Escondido they decide to
continue with an unsustainable system
and they're able to attract employees
away on the basis of promises that will
never be kept we want to see if we can
reset the entire playing field all at
once and a statewide initiative would be
the best way to do that I think the a
lot of local governments use the state
pension fund as well so the local
government still set the benefit levels
that they promised to their employees
but in terms of making the investments
in and and allegedly saving the money to
pay off those benefits they use the
state system so a statewide reform would
trickle down through that anyway by it
by taking away the option of local
governments to assume ridiculous market
returns as they currently do and what
lessons can be learned from your
experience with the unions in San Diego
that would help at the state
wyd level it seems like you guys were
rather successful and how is that going
to translate into working with a at the
state level first the biggest lesson was
that as bad as you think it's going to
be to face the unions and the opposition
tactics that they're going to use it
will be far worse I never imagined what
they would do to try to stop our pension
reform initiative they knew that if we
got this qualified and put it on the
ballot that it would pass overwhelmingly
so what they decided to do was try to
disrupt the constitutional right of the
initiative process itself by blocking
signature gatherers from collecting
signatures and intimidating people
working on the campaign intimidating
members of the public who are interested
in signing the ballot measure they took
out an ad during the period of time when
we were collecting signatures on radio
warning people that if they signed a
ballot measure their identity would be
stolen and sold to India I guess India
is a scary place but but it was the
scare tactics it was the intimidation
the lies that it was pretty shocked I
didn't think they would go that far but
if we do this statewide just recognize
that it will be a battle royale here in
Los Angeles former mayor dick Riordan
sponsored a pension reform initiative to
go to I believe a 401k like system for
the city of Los Angeles which is also
facing a fiscal crisis he encountered
the same resistance the intimidation the
blocking efforts the protests and as a
result his signature drive fell short he
had a discontinued so this will be a
full-on campaign from the moment it is
filed the moment people try qualifying
this initiative because he unions know
that once this is put on the ballot once
people are allowed to vote on reform it
will pass overwhelmingly no amount of
campaign money that they put into a
campaign against the measure will
succeed because people recognize we're
in a crisis and we need to make reform
we're a little a little over time so
we're going to
to stop here I want to thank in everyone
watching online and thank our studio
audience and most of all I want to thank
Carl for the work he's done so far and
for joining team Ruiz actually